huir de un control de tráfico le costó
la vida al afroamericano jeilan walker
cuando al menos ocho agentes de policía
de akrón ohio le dispararon decenas de
veces causando al menos 60 heridas de
bala al hombre de 25 años
no hay duda de que el vídeo que acabamos
de ver es extremadamente inquietante y
despertará muchas emociones y
sentimientos es impactante y difícil de
asimilar y es que a pesar de que la
policía asegura que dispararon desde el
coche de walker mientras huía éste iba
desarmado cuando lo asesinaron
rowan de niza
quiero agradecer al teniente por una
cosa que dijo en el momento en el que le
dispararon más de 60 o 90 veces sea la
cifra que sea y va desarmado
igual
no era un criminal
estaba claramente sufriendo
no merecía morir
un hecho que ha causado indignación y
protestas contra el racismo
ya que este es el último de los muchos
asesinatos de hombres negros a manos de
la policía estadounidense un fenómeno
que los expertos tachan de racista e
injustificado
era probablemente una de las personas
más positivas que he conocido así que
cuando me enteré de la noticia fue como
pensé que se habían equivocado con los
nombres manuel y cada día el hecho de
despertarme y saber que ya no puedo
hablar con él ahora la oficina de
investigación criminal de ohio está
llevando a cabo una investigación
independiente que durará varias semanas
y de momento los policías implicados en
el tiroteo están de baja administrativa